Hello and welcome the fire of learning.
The African pygmys or the Congo pygmies are one of the most unusual and
interesting groups of people on the entire planet.
Hailing from central Africa and the modern countries of the Democratic Republic
of the Congo,
Uganda,
Rwanda,
Burundi,
the Republic of the Congo and other neighboring countries to people are named
for their unusual short stature.
The word pygmy comes from the Greek word [inaudible],
which means dwarf.
The average male comes in at four foot 11 inches on average or 1.5 meters,
much shorter than the average of the neighboring band,
two populations and much in Subsaharan Africa averaging at five,
six or 1.6800000000000002 meters as groups to pygmies often prefer to be
referred to by their regional group names rather than by the collective general
term.
Pygmy though,
as there is no alternative group name for these people as a whole,
the word remains in use academically.
The three main categories here are the Mbanga located here,
the in booty located here,
and the terroir located here.
Within these three groups are around 12 subgroups and total there are between at
900,000 and a million pygmies living in the central African rain forest up to
60% of which live in the DRC.
Though these groups share common traits and lifestyles.
Some groups are not even related to each other.
Having diverged from each other as far back as 20,000 years ago for unknown
reasons,
possibly displacement by other people's or changing climate,
separating east from west altogether,
the pygmies diverged from other African peoples over 60,000 years ago.
Keep in mind,
Europeans have only been in Europe for about 30,000 years and indigenous
Americans only arrived to the Americas around 17,000 years ago.
The species,
Homo sapiens in general is about 200,000 years old.
This makes the African pygmys one of the most ancient and genetically distinct
peoples on the planet.
Second only to native Khoisan populations of South Africa.
In regard to age.
The pygmies are believed to be the direct descendants of African stone age
hunter gatherers though their origins and genetic makeup are a subject of great
debate and a number of different theories.
They as a group existed considerably isolated from other African populations
only until relatively recently having been disturbed by Bantu populations around
two to 3000 years ago and the band to expansion.
However,
genetic evidence shows few foreigners have left a genetic mark and pygmy DNA
before this time.
However,
there is more pigment DNA in surrounding people's suggesting women were chosen
as wives by other groups and were removed from their tribes and the main pygmy
gene pool increased between peoples came during the aforementioned banned to
expansion a period where the Bantu people from modern west Africa began
expanding throughout the continent,
driven by agriculture and later by 400 BC.
The use of iron.
Much of this expansion is still a mystery as there is limited archaeology in the
region and very little in the way of written records.
The pygmy population possibly went through a bottleneck in his time and
fractured into the various smaller groups of today as disease at the pygmies and
conflict between the two groups arose.
The van who's still very much around today constitute much of the population of
southern and central Africa and are the dominant group of the nations in which
the pygmies live.
The two groups began interacting and trading in his time as well and today much
of the pygmy languages are heavily influenced by Ben two languages.
In fact,
they are mostly Bantu.
The origin of the short stature of the African pygmys is another subject which
is not well understood as it is unclear if the eastern and western pygmies
diverged from a common short ancestor or if they adapted the same traits
separately in a response to a similar environment known in biology as convergent
evolution.
The latter possibility is supported by the fact that eastern and western pygmies
have different growth patterns.
A subject which we'll get into the shared environment of the two being of
course,
the Central African jungle to which for unknown reasons,
again,
possibly climate change or displacement,
they were restricted because of their hunter gatherer lifestyle.
Today,
the eastern and western pygmies not only consider themselves separate,
but many have little knowledge of the other's existence,
highlighting just how separated they are,
the short stature,
one of the shortest of any people in the world may have evolved for a number of
reasons,
possibly a combination including a lack of protein and the forest and
environments,
a lack of sunlight,
which leads to a lack of vitamin D and thus having a shorter build would mean
needing less and adaptation to requiring fewer calories to survive in a harsher
jungle environment.
Increased mobility in the forest or to regulate body temperature in grid or heat
and humidity.
Pygmies reached their mature height at the age of 11 to 13 it is unknown when
the pygmies first entered the historical record as they themselves had no system
of writing and references to shorter African people are ambiguous.
An example of this is an ancient Egyptian reference to the dancing dwarves of a
far off land.
This may be one of the earliest accounts of the pygmies,
but it could also refer to a number of other peoples including mythological
ones.
The Bantu who haven't habit in the region for the past few thousand years often
regard them as inferiors because of their forest dwelling,
hunter gathering lifestyle,
a perspective which lasts this day as we'll get into when Europeans arrived in
the 19th century to explore Africa more thoroughly,
they came to share this perspective and had little interest in them apart from a
scientific or anthropological curiosity.
The Belgians who had come to dominate much of the Congo even brought many to be
featured in anthropology exhibits in Europe and the US,
which in some circumstances were basically zoos.
The most famous example was a pygmy named Ota Benga brought to the United States
whom visitors took a great interest in for the story of his origins,
his height and his teeth.
Pygmy teeth are often richly sharpened and youth which in their culture is found
to be attractive.
His life story is a tragic one as just as he was on the verge of returning home.
World War One broke out,
preventing has returned,
sending him into a depression and he committed suicide while living and working
in Virginia.
The internal culture and lifestyle of the pygmies is very unique as a people
depending on the jungle forest,
their mythology and religion is very focused on it,
believing it to be a sacred place.
Marriage is often arranged by the tribes where men exchange,
sisters and husbands present.
A wife's parents with an antelope has killed on his own.
There are notable instances of polygamy,
though marriage is seen as very important and these soul times sexual
intercourse and reproduction is permitted.
Pygmies seem to reach maturity faster than other humans with girls as young as
eight being capable of reproduction.
Linguistically,
the group,
as I said,
speaks a number of largely banned two languages,
but also French,
especially when interacting with non-Pygmies,
which is an aftereffect of Belgian rule.
The group often lacks clear power structures and social structures except when
hunting where the most experienced and efficient males are essentially made
leader.
The groups often work cohesively.
Those who break rules within society are sometimes scorned,
beaten or banished.
However,
on the whole they are stereotypically considered a peaceful,
cooperative and gentle people.
They are often well known for their music which is polyphonic and a part of
everyday life singing quite often while working on various tasks.
While they have prospered for thousands of years in this lifestyle when left on
their own,
there are very poorly integrated into modern African,
specifically Bantu to society.
I mentioned earlier that the band twos regard pygmies as inferiors.
Though this is an understatement when you look at the modern relationship
between the two effectively many band twos to not even consider pygmies actual
humans.
In the DRC where pygmies are 2% of the population,
they are often slaves who are occasionally paid and things like clothing,
cigarettes and alcohol.
Of course,
pay is not guaranteed.
Pygmies are not viewed as true citizens.
They are denied land rights,
education,
healthcare,
citizenship and political representation.
Many African companies involving logging food production and poaching often
encroach on her land,
threatening their native lifestyle along with height.
The IQ,
average and life expectancies of the pygmies are some of the lowest in the world
as well.
These people are accordingly,
often greatly on the losing end of any conflict in this region.
During the 1994 over one in genocide orchestrated by the Hutu government,
nearly one third of the pygmy population or 10,000 people were killed in a much
worse incident known as a Foss Sila,
tableau and the Second Congo war up to 70,000 pygmies were killed in a genocide.
These killings were greatly unusual as the pygmy say,
they were hunted like wild animals and there are disturbing reports of
cannibalism by Congolese militias who claim that pygmy flesh granted them a form
of magical power.
It is because of all this encroachment on a land and slave meant to work in
bent.
Who Farms and industries intermarriage with ventouse extreme poverty in ms
treatment and genocide that they are facing extinction as a people,
what do you think about the pygmies and what should be done concerning their
future?
Let me know in the comments section below if you enjoyed this video.
I have made others like it here at fire of learning.
We cover subjects like this and on many other subjects like history,
science,
philosophy,
and much more,
and I'd invite you to come check those videos out and to subscribe to see more
in the future.
Thank you for watching.